they're escaping gang violence in
port-au-prince
over 500 people are seeking refuge in
this port stadium under the protection
of the red cross
among the displaced are almost 100
children and pregnant women
but it's not just the gangs they're
afraid of in the middle of a pandemic
it's also covet 19.
we are afraid because we don't know when
the virus will hit us that's why we're
asking the government to do something
for us because we've lost everything
during the gang violence
for the past year and a half of the
covet 19 pandemic
the number of cases in haiti have been
considered to be low
but in may the numbers of cases started
to rise
dr boyer princa who is working at the
hospital in port-au-prince says
she has already lost friends and
relatives to covert 19.
we understand that kova became a big
reality in haiti now not like before
when we have one or two
cases and we had doubt about this
disease but now there are a lot of
families affected by covid
and we also hear more and more people
are dying from the disease
haiti is the poorest country in the
americas it has only around 240 coveted
19 beds for its population of over 11
million people
the increase of covert in haiti is a
problem a lot of our hospitals are
already occupied and we don't have a big
center for covert that can take
200 300 patients at the same time
haiti has not received a single vaccine
dose yet to prevent coronavirus
a lack of resources infrastructure and
testing
are a major concern the numbers of cases
and deaths are relatively low compared
to other countries
but doctors say the actual figures are
probably much higher
the country is also now in the middle of
a political crisis
protesters have been taken to the
streets against the government's
attempts to reform the constitution
and gangs seem to be in control of
entire areas across the country
many are afraid of going to a hospital
and being caught in a firefight
we are the state in this country the
police is not strong enough to do
anything
without us nothing can function in this
country the pan-american health
organization says
haiti will be receiving vaccines soon
through the kovacs distribution system
it is also helping increase supplies
of protective equipment for health
workers
but it's the violence and insecurity
that has many terrified in the country
a major problem when trying to fight a
deadly infectious disease
teresa al jazeera